good morning belief nation today's
message is be in the right place at the
right time over to you Kimora Lee
Simmons advice for someone that's
looking to start their own business I
feel like some of it has to do with
alignment and timing and being in the
right place at the right time which for
me when I was younger I never was in the
right place at the right time it may
seem like I was with my career but it
was always very difficult for me but
then as you know as you grow you and
time goes on you sort of learn that that
alignment and being in the right place
and the right time is by choices that
you make people that you choose to be
around like-minded people you know you
all you know you always need like I said
help like a hand a help up always to try
to put yourself I always wanted to be
like the dumbest person I know that
doesn't sound right I wanted to be with
people that were bigger than me better
than me smarter than me I wanted those
to be my friends because I wanted to
learn from them like what like a sponge
and I think it's really about alignment
and where you place yourself and having
help and support it could be from your
family it could be someone just looking
at you that day and saying you know
you're great I believe in you you could
do this it could be someone else that's
um helping you build and grow your
business or I'm going to invest in you
I'm going to help you do this I really
believe in you there is like so many
things but you have to kind of be open
to it and be in the right place at the
right time but I think I mean that in a
way that you can put yourself in the
right place at the right time by what
you choose to do what you choose to be
how you choose to represent yourself who
you choose to hang around in a community
like this it's always positive
information creative people you're
growing you're changing you can bounce
ideas off of one another
I think that's follow your passion do
things that you love probably answering
50 questions at once already but you all
understand right you guys have heard me
talk about how important in an
environment
is over and over and over on this
channel again most entrepreneurs have an
environment that do not support
themselves if you want to do great
things you'll be surrounded by greatness
it's a message I've repeated
consistently and I want to share an
example with you you know if you wanted
to go and learn Japanese so that was
your goal I want to learn Japanese the
fastest way to do it is it go to Japan
right immerse yourself in the culture
force yourself to pick it up because
people there may not speak English to
you right where most people what they do
is they pick up a textbook or maybe they
go to a class or maybe they try to
schedule a one-on-one Skype session with
somebody who knows Japanese or schedule
a coffee meeting or go to a meet-up and
those can all work if you keep at it but
the growth is so much slower compared to
moving to Japan you're going to pick up
Japanese really quickly and I think
that's a challenge for a lot of
entrepreneurs you want to be a
successful entrepreneur you want to be
surrounded by these great ideas and
build great ideas up yourself but you're
kind of doing things on the side part
time in terms of building your
environment right you're you're not
going to Japan
you're not diving in you're not trying
to surround yourself with the best
people possible you're not consuming the
information and the wisdom and the
knowledge that is part of the top ten
series and part of the answer series and
other places that you could go on just
the physical space that you're in and
the people that you're hanging out with
you're doing it in spurts right you're
doing it like reading from a textbook
and that gives you a little bit of a
jolt and then you're back down to your
regular terrible environment and so if
you want to feel like the big dreams
that you have are possible then you need
to examine everything in your
environment and figure out is this
conducive to me achieving my big goal
because probably it's not and there's a
lot of life changes that you have to
make from what's on the walls to who
your friends are to what you read every
day to the videos you watch the morning
routine to the habits that you have to
the food that you eat to your regular
exercise everything look at everything
look at every 10 minutes of your day and
the activities that you're doing in the
physical space that you're in does that
lead you to do great things or not and
the more those 10 minute chunks that you
can
line properly the closer you'll get to
achieving your goal so the question
today today is are you surrounded with
enough people that push you to be the
best version of yourself I'm curious to
find out leaving the comments below I'm
going to join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event espresso